the liberal media is desperately
searching for a Joe Biden replacement
and it looks like mayor Pete is at the
top of the list the transportation
secretary best known for overseeing
disaster after disaster during his
tenure is now getting glowing puff
pieces from the Press check out this
headline from Wired Magazine quote Pete
bootage loves God beer and his electric
Mustang but wait it gets even more
ridiculous the article Praises oh Pete
for his quote voluminous mind his
Cathedral mind the Curious mind of Pete
his cabinet job requires only a modest
portion of his cognitive Powers but it
gets more ridiculous with these
questions quote are there more ways that
challenges of Transportation speak to
your spiritual side and it looks like
the media is praising mayor Pete because
the alternative is much worse the White
House has been trying to elevate Kamala
Harris but then we ended up with this
first question let's start with your
favorite song of all time
oh my favorite song of all time
I was gonna say something from Bootsy
but
I mean I don't know
Dalek yeah okay I mean I am 28. Bob
Marley for sure okay okay
um
there's a range I have a range but I'm A
hip-hop kid that's how I grew up
all right Jesse we know the White House
is trying to repair Harris's image
problem and put her out there more but
what was the goal of having Kamala do
this interview with a small time
YouTuber and wait it got 3 000 views in
three days again we are trying to
reintroduce Kamala Harris to the voters
and what they don't understand is it's
not about kamala's personality it's
about her performance we're not dating
Kamala Harris we don't need to know what
her favorite song is her favorite salad
dressing we just want to know if she can
perform because we're going to hire her
if that's what they want and that's not
the kind of question you ask people
you're trying to hire now Pete I read
this thing can you name a transportation
secretary that's got a gushing puff
piece like this the answer is no because
this guy is running for president look
how many boxes this guy checks for a
democratic nominee they say he's smart
he's a veteran he lifts weights he's in
a a relationship he plays the piano yet
he also splits wood he not only likes
cheeseburgers he also likes impossible
Burgers he loves God but he really loves
blacks gays women and the poor
can't check this many boxes
it's like Sultan came up with some
to be honest with you and especially the
fact that I know he's got a electric
Mustang yep yeah that's not that's not
what I think you need Pete you know Dana
the author of this Buddha judge p uh
peace Wright said he loves God beer and
his electric Mustang but how about
asking about the train derailments the
flight cancellations the supply chain
his extended paternity leave none of
that comes in yeah I feel like this
reporter at wired needed an Editor to
say uh go back and try again but and
maybe the reporter himself was like this
enamored but they're just the total
blind spot that they have the other
thing is you only do a glowing profile
or agree to do a profile piece once
you've done something of significance
that's another life lesson right you
don't do it when on the back of end of
the East Palestine you wait now the
other thing is the media keeps trying to
make Pete bootage a thing the Democratic
party the voters themselves the
Grassroots of the democratic party don't
want him as their thing and the media
keeps trying to shove it down their
throats that you are going to like him
because it checks all of the boxes and I
think that he would be better off just
like doing some great work seeing how
the travel season goes this summer right
because everybody's going to want to
know that's what people are going to
want to know how are the roads how are
the trains how are the planes and that's
that's what's going to matter I do
honestly wanted to mention that I think
I said this on Jesse's show last night
the White House is trying to be very
very sneaky on the Kamala Harris reboot
because yes that YouTube only got 3 000
views right but that woman that did the
interview she has 6.5 million likes on
tick tock
and that's where they're look they want
you to think that they're only just
doing YouTube when it's actually a tick
tock star that they're going after while
they still try to fight with the Chinese
while the president's in Japan at the G7
you know uh Tom they talk about the fact
that uh the writer says they slowly
became aware of Buddha judges cabinet
job requires only a small modest portion
of his cognitive Powers
um and it's it appears now that Buddha
judge beats Biden and Democrat voters
pick of 2024 23 to 18. what's stopping
Pete from actually jumping into the game
well maybe he realizes as well I agree
with Dana the voters don't like him it's
interesting the two people we were
talking about here was Pete butterjudge
and Kamala Harris and they both were set
up by the press as being the ultimate
candidate we never heard she's the
perfect candidate but the voters didn't
like her either how about Robert Kennedy
Jr who's polling pretty well against the
president why does anybody mention him
and you know what a lot of red State
people that I know they like RFK Jr and
about the only thing he has in common
with President Trump is that they were
both banned from Twitter
interesting interesting all right Harold
what do you think so I come from an era
when when you and you work for the
president you work for the pleasure at
the pleasure of the president you should
behave like that uh if I were in the
White House I'd be disappointed
um that he would have done this uh and
that the kind of attention that he's
getting number two I think if I were the
transportation secretary I'd be focused
on if I wanted to get out and get some
Press On My Own I'd want to get out and
talk about some of the infrastructure
successes and go into cities and states
and talk about those things that DNS
East Palestine trying to figure out what
can we do testing to ensure that
people's property but that's what you
would do the fact that he's not well I
can only answer the question how I would
answer it I mean so I would be doing
different things if I were him trying
and if I were in the White House and say
these are the things you need to be
doing now he's chosen not to do that and
he's chosen to do this this is a a
really an error in politics where people
think that having social media followers
uh getting on television is the only
thing you need to do in order to be in
politics it happens on both sides of the
aisle I give DeSantis a little credit he
at least is doing something I disagree
with a lot what he's doing with Disney
and education here but at least he's
amassed a record that he's going to get
out and campaign on Tim Scott the same
weight Pence the same way if you want to
run for office have an agenda have a
message have a vision have a platform
not a social media platform but actually
something substantive so if I'm in the
white house I'd be disappointed that my
Transportation secretary was and as
former Congressman Harold Ford are you
disappointed in him
I would if I were the president United
States I'd be disappointed you have an
opinion Harold well clearly clearly I I
would much rather see the transportation
secretary talking about those issues the
Energy Secretary talking about I mean
this is not the Milan Jennifer Garner
but this is not what I would want my
Transportation disappointment is a
strong word for Harold yeah I guess you
went that far okay hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else